etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video
jetzt knallt aber ganz schön hier ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut ich
freue mich sehr dass heute video zu
machen ich bin so gespannt ja ich habe
nachgeschaut ich habe das noch jeden
vorgesehen in deutschland und ich hoffe
das ist so klappt wie ich mir das
vorstelle viele von euch haben jetzt
wahrscheinlich den titel gelesen und
dachten sich hat ist das sinzig border
hört sich erstmal eigentlich relativ
langweilig an casus wasser oder so voll
dictate das ist ja dann der unterschied
das heißt nicht sich sondern dick also
dickes wasser ich habe das bei einigen
amerikanischen youtube angesehen und in
amerika ist das echt und denken da
kannst du abgefüllt ist dick oder kaufen
sie dann ungefähr so aus kann ich euch
sehr gerne mal hier einbinden
ich wollte das bestellen das problem der
gewesen das kommt erst in eineinhalb
monaten an und es hätte irgendwie 6
dollar gekostet plus 60 euro versandt
oder so dann ab 66 euro für wasser das
kann man sich auch sparen ich habe
allerdings eine andere methode gefunden
und zwar konnte ich ganz entspannt bei
amazon dieses produkt bestellen
ticketpreis dass es gibt wohl eine
krankheit die nennt sich durch magie
also ich glaube dass es die krankheit
ist da geht es um schluckbeschwerden
oder auch refluxkrankheit macht weiß ich
es auch latte wir schauen uns mal ganz
kurzen video an von jemanden der das
schon getestet hat leute gebt euch das
mal
jetzt achtet darauf jetzt schöne wäre
das ein oder das ist wirklich so wichtig
dickflüssig nur das dickflüssiges wasser
und jetzt hier noch ganz kurz jetzt
trinkt ja diesen halben meter achtet
darauf dass sieht einfach ganz komisch
aus bringt er jetzt weg ok kommen damit
so richtig schlimm ich liebe dich so
richtig dick halt war ja und ich sitze
hier um das einfach mal nach zu machen
also wie schon gesagt wir haben hier
ticken ab instant pulver zur anlegung
von flüssigkeiten geschmacksneutral also
ohne geschmack habe ich das jetzt
einfach mal bestellt und wir wollen das
jetzt hier rein und gucken was passiert
ja das riecht auf jeden fall noch nix
ich will mal eben kurzen löffel hey
leute ich finde so gespannt was jetzt
passiert ich nehme ein bisschen so viel
und tue das hier rein
okay man sieht schon dass es sich auf
jeden fall sehr gut verteilt ich würde
mal sagen ein bisschen geht noch und
jetzt fröhlich das ganze mal um
ich hab grad in kurzen cup gesetzt ich
habe das big brother ein richtiger
zungenbrecher jetzt hier einfach mal an
diese flasche gefüllt
ihr seht das wahrscheinlich um diesen
effekt zu erzielen das wenn man das eine
ist das ist so richtig schwein lichter
rein läuft und das machen wir jetzt
einfach mal
ich hoffe es klappt aber ich bin nicht
da ist ziemlich sicher das ist wirklich
jetzt richtig dick flüssig geworden aber
es riecht einfach nach gar nichts mehr
ich bin gespannt ob ich das runter
kriegen jetzt passt auch leute
alter das ist ja dickflüssiger als dich
jetzt vielleicht habe ich da ein
bisschen zu viel von diesem mittelrhein
gefüllt scheiße mann wenn ich das weg
kriegen sollten wir ziehen das durch
natürlich zieht natürlich kriege ich das
weg ich glaube aber ein bisschen weniger
von diesem mittel jetzt auch getan alter
gibt euch das mal ganz gestört ich habe
mir schon die verrücktesten dinge
ausgemalt man könnte das hier auch mit
cola machen mit fanta und so was alles
das mache ich ganz wichtig leute trinken
wasser am tag
hey das ist viel zu dick das ist wie
wenn du kurz muss wenn ihr zu viel
alkohol getrunken habt und euch
übergeben müsste damit ihr wieder nicht
dann werdet glaubt mir trinkt einfach
ein schluck pick oder dann geht es
direkt los okay was ich kann doch jetzt
nicht sein also das ist aber auch
wirklich viel dickflüssiger als von
diesem typen oder ok einer versuche ich
das jetzt noch
okay leute das hier ist jetzt deutlich
weniger also zumindest ein bisschen
weniger und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob ich das runter kriegen weil das hier
keine chance ich muss davon safe kurzem
habe ich ja schon was aber diese
mischung sollte eigentlich klar gehen
wobei ich auch sagen muss das ist
natürlich irgendwie nicht so schlimm ich
darum geht wie bei dem typ im video
keine ahnung was dann in diesem original
fig border drin ist aber ich habe halt
im internet nachgeschaut und da stand
dass man das auch so machen kann wenn
ihr das weststadt ist gamer in die
kommentare hier haben was ja auch schon
sehr klebrig nevzat weiter ich probier's
mal let's go
es ist halt wirklich einfach nur
ekelhaft nur was ich mich wirklich frage
wie schmeckt cola wenn ich fertig sind
so dick ist wie dieses ding hier also
das werden wir auf jeden fall noch
herausfinden
ich glaube damit kann man das ganz gut
beenden
ich hoffe es hat euch halbwegs gefallen
also ich wollte es halt einfach mal
testen wir sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr
wieder gibt's neues video zeigt gern
mein alex v kanal ab da gibt es auch
jeden tag neues wie du das war es von
mir
hard rain zu abonnieren